maybe you should just
take some time apart you never even want
to do anything anymore
and every time i bring something up
you're always freaking quiet like it's
like you don't even like me anymore
just freaking leave okay wait
i'm sleeping oh okay well let's do
something like
freaking crazy tonight be spontaneous
baby's late i'm trying to sleep you
never want to have fun anymore
like you're like a freaking grandpa i
want to
party i want to like do stuff
okay i'm up
[Music]
sir
sarah got me
sounds like miami's partying with us
tonight all right
let's reach okay what do you mean
okay like let's freaking party let's get
in party mode like we're young
growing out a good time
take it seriously babe
okay got this for me
all right cheers
if i get a little crazy again
just take care of me okay here we go
well maybe maybe you slow down a little
bit you're like wait
no
[Music]
are you hungry what do you want
pasta
do you think yogurt could go with pasta
sure
[ __ ] yeah
okay is then
oh what's this oh don't don't
you're a freaking murderer
[Music]
we're all done
not on the couch oh no
i'll clean it
going live
own the game we should live stream this
[ __ ]
and show everybody how to put it
i think this is yours
do you even lift bruh hey
gonna have fun it's a good one
[Music]
go snap this pic premiere up right quick
for instance
yes
[Music]
hmm